للمره السابعه في تاريخها تامر حسني في
كاس السوبر المصري وسعد المجرد يحتفي
بنجاح اش اخبارك اليكم الابرز الاسبوع
الماضي
[موسيقى]
فازت المغنيه السويديه من اصول المغربيه
لورين بمسابقه يورو فيجن الغنائيه لعام
2023 وذلك للمره الثانيه في مسيرتها بعد
11 عاما على فوزها الاول بالمسابقه وحققت
لورين للسويد اللقب السابع في منافسات
اليورو فيجن الغنائيه والتي نظمتها
بريطانيا هذا العام باسم اوكرانيا في
مدينه ليفربول
واستكمالا لجولتها الغنائيه التي تشمل
دولا في افريقيا والشرق الاوسط والهند
احيت فرقه باك ستريت بويز الشهيره حفلا في
جده ضمن اجواء وصفت بالحماسيه
وبعد الجدل الذي واكب حفلها الاخير في مصر
احيت اصاله حفلا ضمن فعاليات مهرجان صيف
الكويت جمعها بالمغنيه اللبنانيه اليسا
التي حققت تفاعلا كبيرا على وسم اليسا في
الكويت الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما احتفى محبو المطرب المصريه انغام على
منصات التواصل بحفلها ضمن فعاليات
المهرجان ذاته وكذلك الفنان المصري تامر
حسني الذي غنى الاسبوع الماضي ايضا في
مباراه كاس السوبر المصري على استاد محمد
بن زايد بمدينه ابو ظبي بين فريقي
بيراميدز والاهلي وتوج فيها نادي القرن
بكاس البطوله للمره الثالثه عشره في
تاريخه
ونبقى في اجواء الغناء حيث واصل الفنان
المغربي سعد المجرد الاحتفاء بنجاح اغنيته
الجديده اش اخبارك والتي تجاوز عدد
مشاهداتها مؤخرا ال14 مليون مشاهده على
قناته الرسميه على يوتيوب سعد قال انه صور
الاغنيه بالكامل في المغرب واصدرها بعد
حصوله مؤخرا على اطلاق سراح مؤقت بانتظار
استئناف محاكمته بقضيه الاغتصاب والاعتداء
على شابه فرنسيه في غرفه فندق بباريس
والتي حكم عليه فيها بالسجن لست سنوات
والى مصر وبالتزامن مع عرض منصه نتفليكس
في فيلم عن كليوباترا اظهرها ببشره سمراء
وملامح افريقيه اقيمت دعوتين قضائيتين
لوقف المنصه في مصر والغاء عرض الفيلم
وتعويض يقدر بمليارين دولار عما وصف
بالاضرار التاريخيه التي حملها الفيلم
جراء تزييف الحقائق والتاريخ المصري كما
شارك وانتج عالم الاثار المصري زاهي حواس
فيلما وثائقيا عن الملكه كليوباترا عرض
على عده منصات عالميه في يوم عرض الفيلم
على منصه نتفليكس
ونختتم الابرز الاسبوع الماضي بخبر رحيل
الصوت الجريح المطرب الكويتي عبد الكريم
عبد القادر بعد معاناه مع المرض بحسب
وكاله الانباء الكويتيه التي ذكرت ان
الفنان الراحل اثرى خلال مشواره الممتد
لنحو سته عقود المكتب الغنائيه الكويتيه
والخليجيه والعربيه ونعت وزاره الاعلام
الكويتيه الفنان الراحل وكذلك العديد من
الفنانين الكويتيين والعرب
[موسيقى]
وفي لفته تكريميه للممثل السوري الراحل
محمد قنوع حمل جمهور نادي الوحده الدمشقي
صورته على المدرجات خلال مباراه لكره
السله اقيمت في العاصمه السوريه الاسبوع
الماضي